right is the queen of comedy is he about
to lose his crown in the recipe
challenge tonight do declare you're
about to find out good to see aren't you
yep good luck what's it called
I wanted this stuff something in front
of you and rice okay appropriate it is
cold stats sardines stuff sardines
what'd you stuff them with and hacks and
pistachios and bulgur wheat are you fond
of a good stuffing I'm gonna do
something I'm very similar of its
marinade them and then grill them in a
Moroccan spice Jamuna this is Jeffrey
you've named them are you quite
competitive I'm very competitive
are you an alpha male do you think I'm
an alpha male well you're kind of the
epitome very energetic and quite
aggressive aren't you aggressive at me
passion
so in here I've got my marinade I've got
the coriander the cumin and paprika now
the idea is to score the sardines
lightly with a knife so the marinade can
penetrate through and really get inside
that wonderful delicious fish have you
had Botox Julia I have yeah how did it
go all right the feeling of the needle
hitting the bone did it hurt what now
that's a bit under the eyes but not on
the forehead really are you boning your
sod things out I'm taking the spine out
who taught you that I taught myself
that's Geoffrey done I'm gonna [ __ ]
good job all right
I'm nearly done
so mine's ready to go in the oven are
you ready okay now that was quick in way
carefully into the griddle
I've got couscous with in lemon zest
some raisins a little bit of chopped
coriander and the toast some almonds Oh
hurry out I love it yeah we reached 30
seconds I love the way you bossed me
around now great when was our family had
a nice dinner part in the countryside
two weeks to go broody
we were happy through eating and a snake
came through the door oh my god have you
ever eaten a snake no hope that is a
genuine question I didn't mean now side
by side here's the exciting part off you
go
obviously come back with the right
result good luck